♪♪
-Hello, everybody,
and welcome to "Corrections,"
week of Tuesday, August 17th.
I feel like we always
overvalue Monday.
Tuesday was just as important
in making this a week.
Let's start with the fact
that I complained that
Vince Vaughn wasn't in "Loki."
I thought it would be great
if he and Owen Wilson
were in "Loki" together.
And plus, he could then say,
"Buddy, buddy, buddy,"
because there
were three Lokis.
And then we showed a picture,
and a lot of you pointed out
that the photo we showed,
there were actually four Lokis
because there was
Alligator Loki.
The problem is,
my Vaughn only works
with three "buddies."
"Buddy, buddy, buddy" --
that's Vince Vaughn.
"Buddy, buddy, buddy, buddy" --
it could be anyone.
I said "PIN number."
The "N" in PIN is "number."
So when I say PIN number,
I'm saying personal
identification number number.
It was an error.
Or an homage!
To my favorite "Goodfellas"
character, Johnny Two Times.
[ Laughter ]
We talked about cliff diving.
I talked about wearing
a squirrel suit
to go cliff diving,
then I got correct and I said
I meant to say BASE diving.
It's BASE jumping.
BASE is an acronym.
Do you know what it stands for,
Shoemaker?
-Nope.
-Why do I come to you?
[ Laughter ]
It's the four things you can
jump off.
BASE is buildings; antennae;
spans, meaning bridges;
and earth, meaning cliffs.
Alright, there's a poll,
a company, an organization --
I don't even know
what they are --
Quinnipiac.
I think I said Quinni-PI-ac.
So here's what I want you to do.
Quin-NI-piac or Quinni-PI-ac.
I need everybody
to take out their phones.
If you think the first one
was right, press 1.
[ Laughter ]
We talked about flutes and how
there are no left-handed flutes.
So people said to me,
there actually -- there are
left-handed flutes.
They're expensive,
but there's a company, Viento.
A couple of people said
Viento makes them.
So I looked it up,
and there is a company,
a German company, Viento,
that makes left-handed flutes.
They're not a sponsor.
Okay, this is not --
we've never had a sponsor
in "Corrections."
That's not what this is about.
But I did think it would be fun.
I would like to.
Maybe I'll just do
an ad for them
and then with the hopes that
they just have a massive week.
Right? They sell more --
Like, the left-handed flutes are
just flying off the shelves.
Then they'll come back to us
and say, "Oh, my God,
that was great,"
and then we'll have them
over a barrel.
"A newcomer to the United States
instrument market,
Viento flutes are a fine value
for the money.
These flutes are designed
for entry-level flutists
and are built to take
the challenges
that a young owner
can present a flute."
Very eggy language there.
I double-checked
before I said it
'cause I thought
it was "flautists."
Either work.
Flutist or flautist
are the same.
So, a flutist
would sound like this.
[ Flute trills ]
And a flautist would sound
like this.
[ Flute trills ]
And a flatulist
would sound like this.
[ Fart noise ]
[ Laughter ]
That is base humor,
which means...
[ Laughter ]
...it's funny in a building...
[ Laughs ]
Oh, I misspoke.
I just said a word wrong.
I said that Mike Lindell
was a pillow magnet.
He's a pillow magnate.
He is a lawsuit magnet.
[ Laughter ]
I also said that My Pillows --
as a joke --
I jokingly said they were filled
with rock-hard calcified turds.
Which people told me
there's a word for -- coprolite.
It's not a correction; that was
just like a helpful, like,
"Hey, Seth,
here's some new vocab for you."
So, coprolite.
And I should stress,
they are not filled
with rock-hard calcified turds.
And just out of good faith,
I went on the
My Pillow website today
to try to find out
what they were filled with.
Could not find out.
Not a helpful website.
With everything else.
This is true.
This was in the FAQs.
I went to the FAQs
on the website
trying to find out
what's in a My Pillow.
There were only six.
There were only six FAQs.
One was, "Can I get My Pillow
in Canada?"
You've been frequently
asked that?
This one was very --
it said,
"How do I know
what pillow I have?"
This is a frequently
asked question.
"Yellow will have yellow
writing on the tag.
White will have black
Green will have green
writing on the tag.
Blue will have blue
writing on the tag."
I don't know why they did
a white one
that had black
writing on the tab.
Starting to think this guy
and I think differently.
[ Laughter ]
Also, a lot of people have said,
based on my impression
of Mike Lindell,
"Hey, he's not from Chicago.
He's from Minnesota.
Stop making him sound like
one of the SNL Super Fans."
And he is from Minnesota, but
I learned a lesson this year.
And that lesson is, sometimes
what you want to be true
is more important than
what is actually true.
And I learned that
from Mike Lindell.
I talked about this last week
'cause this was
in last week's correction,
that if Rudy had been told
to book a press conference
at the Waldorf Astoria,
he would book it
at a Walmart in Astoria.
A lot of people said there is
not a Walmart in Astoria.
I corrected myself.
Then some people from Oregon
were like,
"Hey, there's an Astoria
in Oregon that has a Walmart."
So, because we...
Look, when we can,
we will fix the problem.
We will go back
and re-edit "A Closer Look."
So, if you were
to go back now,
this is what you would see.
I'm at the Walmart in
[overdubbed] Astoria, Oregon.
[ Laughter ]
Also, I did double-check.
I don't know if it's actually
in Astoria, Oregon.
It's in Warrenton, Oregon,
which is next door.
So this is a true question
I'm asking
for our Ore-gone-ian --
Ore-go-nian --
people in Oregon.
[ Laughter ]
People of Oregon, be honest.
If I said to you, "Meet me
at the Walmart in Astoria,"
would you know what I meant?
Press 1.
[ Laughter ]
I talked about my contest
with Lorde
about who's a better painter,
and I said that I moved the poll
from the "Late Night"
Twitter account
to the Sea Captain Polls
because I thought there would be
less Lorde fans there.
Fewer Lorde fans there.
Although I also hope they were,
like, just less fans of hers.
Like, still fans, just a little
bit less, and that would...
Okay.
We talked about
"Prince of Tides"
and how I had late fees
because I rented
"Prince of Tides"
from Blockbuster
when I was 18 years old.
And I said, "Yeah,
I rented it when I was 18.
I was one of the kids who liked
watching 'Prince of Tides.'"
And somebody -- a bunch of
people said, "If you were 18,
you weren't a kid."
And now here's the crazy thing.
We had originally written
the joke to say,
"When I was 17,
I rented 'Prince of Tides,'"
so I would have been fine.
This is an actual email
we got from our fact-checker,
noting that
"Seth would have turned 18
on December 28, 1991.
'Prince of Tides'
was released in theaters
Christmas Day 1991.
Unless he somehow got a bootleg
VHS in those three days,
which Blockbuster would
not have been renting,
he would have had to rent
'Prince of Tides'
when he was over 18, in 1992."
The jackals are
inside the house.
[ Laughter ]
I also said it was $60,000
in late fees.
A lot of people
took issue with that.
They said it was a dollar
a day at Blockbuster
and there was a cap.
And even if it was a dollar
a day and there was no cap,
it wouldn't have been $60,000.
But then someone else said,
yeah, but Blockbuster,
what they did was
they actually turned over
all the late fees
to a collection agency.
So it wasn't Blockbuster
trying to get the money.
It was a collection agency.
And that made sense to me
because I remember once
a few years ago -- and again,
I still had
'Prince of Tides,' right?
I hadn't returned it.
I'm in the grocery store.
I'm in, like,
the produce section.
And there's just this guy, this,
like, hulking guy next to me
in the produce section -- he's
just sort of looking over at me.
And finally I look over
and I make eye contact
and he's like, "How you doing?
You okay? You okay?"
And I say, "Yeah, I'm fine."
He goes, "That's good.
'Cause I got a friend,
he's not okay.
Eh, he's not okay."
And I'm like,
"Oh, I'm sorry to hear that."
He goes, "Yeah.
His name's Tom Wingo.
You ever heard of Tom Wingo?"
And I had, because that's
Nick Nolte's character's name
in "Prince of Tides."
But, you know, obviously,
I'm starting to get
a little worried.
I'm like, "I don't think
I have heard of Tom Wingo."
He goes, "Yeah, that's funny,
because I heard you had.
I heard you had
heard about him.
And I want to check up on him,
see what he's done,
see if he's come back
from New York City,
moved back to Charleston.
But I can't, 'cause
you got the tape!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughing ] And I had to
give him 60 grand.
We said that Donald Trump
looked tired the other day
and we said he looked like
he accidentally reached
for a Diet Coke,
but had Sudafed instead.
Many of you said Sudafed --
I should have said Nyquil
because Sudafed is like
basically an amphetamine.
And that's why you need
to show ID to get Sudafed,
because a lot of people
use it illicitly.
And that made sense to me
because I feel like the energy
of those of you
who leave comments --
it has, like, a meth-y energy.
[ Laughter ]
Like that you're all
cranked up on ice.
"Should we watch 'Closer Look'
again and look for flubs?"
Pundit.
We say pundit a lot.
And I don't know why --
I do say "pundint."
And I got to stop doing it.
It's wrong.
I have no defense of it.
I will say...
I wish it was "pundint" so that
when they were wrong --
'cause I think a lot of pundits
go on the cable news shows
and when they come on,
a lot of the things
they say are wrong.
It would be fun, like
six months after the fact,
to do --
you could do like a series.
You could do a feature on your
show, a recurring segment
where you would have
a pundit on,
if they were called
"pundints" --
again, this is me just being
wishful thinking --
where you would show them
something they had said
that they'd gotten wrong,
and you could call it
"Oh, No, You Pundint!"
Emmy voting is open.
This is an Emmy-nominated
piece of content.
We've talked about this.
What we have not talked about
are our fellow nominees
in the category,
all of whom we would be
honored to lose to.
Randy Rainbow,
such a funny gentleman.
You can check him out
on YouTube.
"Carpool Karaoke" -- as good
a recurring segment
on any late-night talk show
in the last decade.
They have a show on Apple.
That's with our friend
James Corden.
"Tooning Out the News" is
this incredibly inventive
cartoon political interview show
that Stephen Colbert
produces -- fantastic.
You kind of have to see it
to believe it.
Do search that out.
And "Reno 911!"
which was a fantastic show
for years on Comedy Central
and had a new season
on Quibi.
And Thomas Lennon and others,
our friends did that show.
And so, you know,
all wonderful shows.
And I don't know if I'm the
right person to say this, but...
I think it's pretty cool
that I mentioned them.
[ Laughter ]
You know?
Didn't have to.
I don't know, I'm just
saying, like --
like, I'm me,
so I can't say, but I feel like
if I wasn't me right now,
I would be like, "Alright!"
[ Laughter ]
But so anyway, I think
all five are just super.
But, you know, the only thing
I'll say is, like...
you know,
we did this together, guys.
Alright. See you next week.